les visiteurs ont eu deux jours pour
partir à la découverte du patrimoine
culturel et institutionnel de la réunion
les musées les établissements publics
ont ouvert gracieusement leurs portes
pour cette 33e édition des journées
européennes du patrimoine
je leur ai déjà visité par contre les
jeux les visiter sous un autre angle
j'étais venu ici à trois ans et n'était
pas revenue depuis maintenant j'ai une
meilleure approche meilleure
connaissance de la réunion de jeu
j'apprécie beaucoup plus en fait moi je
me masse et je mets de la réunion du
coup je trouve que les fédés d'avoir
instauré la journée du patrimoine
ça nous permet de découvrir différents
horizons sans forcément avoir les moyens
de payer tous les sites parce que ça
revient cher quand même et du coup ben
voila je trouve que c'est une bonne
initiative au départ d'avoir instauré
cette somme at on a eu la chance de
pouvoir aller à la préfecture et visiter
un peu la préfecture elle a appris un
peu plus sur l'origine de saint-denis
comment se passait dans tout succès tous
intéressants par rapport pour nous déjà
d' apprendre plus sur notre île c'est
très bien de faire ça cette année les
journées européennes du patrimoine sont
placées sous le thème patrimoine et
citoyenneté à saint denis
les visiteurs venus en famille ont pu
profiter des nombreux ateliers
artistiques mises à leur disposition des
c2 c'est quoi les enfants puissent
imprimer leur propre tirage
donc je propose en fait une série de
petites gravure donc j'ai au préalable
sur le thème du jardin donc des insectes
des plantes et le thème de la mer si
c'est l'atelier on a deux ateliers
prévus pour se poster deux journées du
patrimoine et laak et plus précisément
ici on appelle ça un atelier de
restauration est le principe donc si
vous voulez vous approchez c'est juste 2
complétez les le tableau la photo je
sais pas comment on peut appeler ça avec
les couleurs qui sont imposés sur le
le tableau servant de modèle
plus d'une soixantaine de sites
participent à ces journées
un événement qui permet aux réunionnais
comme aux touristes de découvrir de plus
près le patrimoine de notre île